Republicans in Arizona wasted no time
claiming fraud yesterday there is
absolutely nothing to this but they
wasted no time claiming fraud Charlie
Kirk who lives in Arizona and was very
involved with the Kerry Lake campaign in
Blake Masters tweeting out two-hour wait
minimum at most polling places in
Maricopa Democrats running elections
here knew this would happen traffic jam
by Design don't let them do 2020 again
wait in line and vote
it turns out actually that Democrats
don't run elections in Maricopa County
the Board of Supervisors is four
Republicans and one Democrat
same thing with the County Recorder 2020
was safe and secure in Arizona but they
were starting to catch up on this
Arizona stuff here's Brett Baier saying
it's a little suspicious over there we
kind of knew that this election was
going to happen
you know I mean right now
how about how about we fix the machines
I mean why is this happening can we get
our head around there are going to be
problems all over the country some
problems but
for it to happen here for it to happen
now in this way is kind of strange no
well what you have to remember is it's
not that it's happening it's that
Republicans decided we're going to say
that there's fraud in Arizona
really there were no Waits or very short
weights in most places residents are
allowed to vote at any polling place
they want not just the one nearest their
home and there's a very good NPR piece
Arizona's Maricopa County says it's
identified a solution for voting
equipment issues there was an issue with
a tabulator
um it was dealt with
it was not a huge deal but rest assured
if Kerry Lake loses she's losing right
now but we have to wait until all the
votes are counted if Carrie Lake loses
she will say it was fraud
let's take a quick break and be right
back with a very very busy news day
today
our sponsor magic spoon is the breakfast
cereal that tastes amazing but without
the sugar carbs and the crazy
ingredients magic spoon has taken your
favorite childhood cereals and
brilliantly transformed them into
something you can feel good about eating
because each serving has zero grams of
sugar under five net carbs and is packed
with 13 grams of protein so it'll work
for keto and low carb but it's really
perfect for anyone who wants the
occasional sweet crunchy treat without
the sugar their portfolio of eight plus
unique delicious flavors allow you to
never get bored my favorite is maple
waffle but they've got the classics like
cocoa fruity frosted also cinnamon roll
blueberry muffin our entire team has
been eating magic spoon for years we
love it but if you don't they send you
all your money back it's really easy
magic spoon has been supporting the
David Pacman show for a long time they
always give my audience five dollars off
when you go to magicspoon.com Pacman and
use the code Pacman the link is down
below